ce que vous avez été des gros mytho vous
par exemple ou castaldi c'est quoi plus
gros mytho que vous avez fait j'ai fait
un mytho très très grave
j'ai dit qu'il fallait montrer un faux
permis de fois que vous n'êtes jamais
marine ont réussi à louer un hélicoptère
sans avoir un brevet de pilote
c'est très dangereux je suis parti alors
mais c'est hyper dangereux alors je
serai grand mère je savais un peu
piloter vite mais j'avais pas le brûler
encore ouais
ah oui ça veut dire quoi un peu piloter
tarifaire manège parce que j'ai des
mythos votre a dit tiens à votre indique
qu' à s'était passé pour un millionnaire
pour séduire à jean michel jean michel
maire non jlg galère du béton cette baba
là on vous croira pas à part peut-être
paris s'il tonne
merci c'est valable alors tape fort sur
l'hippodrome de chantilly
on n'en peut plus oui alors nous sommes
en 1995 est un ami de l'attrait ou de
société très riche m'a invité à un
mariage avec que des gens riches
d'accord j'ai honte d'y aller avec ma
petite voiture et donc je ne sais pas ce
qui me passe dans la tête je loue une
voiture de luxe pour trois jours à
l'époque c'est quoi comme voitures dites
vous la marque audi la marque au laser à
ti an oll aurait comme j'ai envie de
maserati donc on va citer d'autres
marques de luxe lada voilà dans heroes
heroes nous on adore ou n'en faut 3 il
en faut treize d'entre nous et ils ont
été très bons à 1000 francs
vous auriez encore 450 euros je loue sa
mais oui je vais un mariage et donc
j'arrive avec ma petite voiture au
mariage on me met aux routes et aux
voitures à côté d'une jeune femme
magnifique
oui donc les gens commencent à dire dis
donc une maserati dernier modèle du bois
ou un essai de la famille etc et je sais
pas pourquoi je m'enfonce dans mon
mensonge
la jeune femme parle de voiture je parle
de voiture je dis je vais vous ramener
chez vous mademoiselle etc
je la ramène chez elle et on donne
rendez vous pour la semaine d'après je
m'en faire toute la semaine et je dis
c'est pas possible je ne m'en plus j'y
vais avec ma modeste voiture que j'avais
ma belle clio ouais donc j'arrive pour
venir la chercher maintenant à ce moment
là elle dit mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette voiture je dis je suis d'
désolé c'est ma vraie voiture et elle
m'a plaqué le rentrant chez elle elle la
vie tu vois c'est mon vrai pointe au 13
juin elle m'a largué là et elle a bien
eu raison non pas parce que j'avais
changé de voiture mais parce que j'avais
vu qu'elle était intéressée saab après
la trêve à l'horizon bras exactement
bragon sans égal et à côté de vous ce
soir
alors il y en a un ou une qui cavale et
une dizaine de mines de crayon pour
simuler une maladie alors déjà faut que
la personne qui peut t'arrêter déjà un
donc avoir mis quoi jean mi bah ouais
donc gens me marc isabelle sa gens me
disent ah ils avaient dit qu'ils vous
oui c'est moi tu va nous raconter le
plus gros mytho que tu as fait dans ta
vie toi en vrai parce que elle en fait à
la famille tôt je vais t'expliquer elle
est en train de vous raconter juste
avant la pause c'est quoi c'est à manger
des rings et élimine les garde pour moi
mais ça c'est vrai que j'étais au cm2 et
marty c'était les mathématiques nova
fallait absolument que je loupe le
l'interrogation écrits de mathématiques
déjà j'avais pris une raclée
deux jours avant il fallait absolument
j'ai loupé un petit copain me dit tu
sais c'est simple tu bouges les mines de
crayon ça te donne une fièvre et la tête
tranquille tu loupes la laine de
rodemack c'est sûr j'en ai bouffé au
moins 20 coupé en petits morceaux
j'ai écrit les mises à mal
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais là est alors à mon jeu déclinant
brest est sûr c'est pas monter sert donc
c'est bien donc j'arrive en coupe à rien
pas sonia de chèvre rien dans nos
maisons
infirmières ne me touches je vous dis ça
va pas la tête je prends ta feuille et
tu fais comme te demander si l'on reste
inconnu ce jour-là que dalle donc zéro
et 9 min but initial
[Applaudissements]
l'essentiel avec un petit copain ou le
pont promet paul il aimait pour de m
j'étais malade à crever attentes
mine de rien la ludique je te préviens
le quéré une mine et c'est un bon
contraste avec le film très met encore
plus en avant les experts c'est pas toi
je te fais ça oui moi je te mets ça sur
un plateau je te le dis ça vous avez
fait remis tout vous avez dit que vous
est il sorti avec une spyker
c'est vrai ce tissage essayé de draguer
une fille il ya deux ans je l'emmène
dans un super restaurant thaï un peu
seuls quarts de fi des présidents
américains depuis des mois d'acheter
deux dames offert
ça permet surtout d'avoir des réductions
au bout du 10e repas six mois que je
suis pas né sont devenus dingues
donc j'ai discuté avec cette charmante
demoiselle et elle me fait des
révélations sur son ex elle me dit que
mon ex bon sens que je peux la mêlée
c'est franck des to be free à d'accord
alors une il faut que je me mettre à son
niveau
donc je lui ai balancé les fêtes je suis
sorti avec une spice girls
lorsque j'étais étudiant à londres ce
qui est complètement faux avec me pose
des questions je me pose des questions
je m'avance assiette mais bin ouais
ouais je m'enfonce ans à tabac brindle 5
bah oui oui vous me connaissez be free
et 58 la croisée j'avais envie de faire
rêver outremangeurs différé venait il
donc à nous pose plein de questions sur
l a été pour totalement fan des spice
girls elle donc là je suis extrêmement
embêter sur sur la situation elle elle
me dit c'est quoi ta sa chanson préférée
et à son centre est fake et d'abus et
qu'elle a pu le chanter ce que je dis
que des gentils avec elle pendant trois
mois et jeudi cc minimes féminines et
vos places
elle s'est levée destiny tornade me
mentir c'est un gros mytho
elle s'est barrée et finalement j'ai
jamais eu m bini la fille donc
[Musique]
c'est la soirée les deux ils parlent de
leur tutelle rp qui moi je sais pas mal
géré les genoux la vérité toi tu sais ce
que tu es bien sortir quelqu'un de connu
moi fouet à l'est est non
bb non non non pas moi hanouna un tu le
saurais je serai appelé tout de suite
allé moi papa me regarde pas je sais que
si tu es morte pour pas que daniel et à
la télé voilà la femme de franck et
c'est quoi le plus gros mytho pts effet
je sais pas j'en ai fait plein à bah oui
c'est un moment et il ya très longtemps
ouais je faisais croire que j'étais
sorti à l'époque j'ai dit non non non ce
que ça avec une des filles qui jouaient
dans la petite maison dans la prairie
mais mélissa gilbert psg qui faisait qui
je sais pas alors je savais qu'elle fait
le régal et je sais pas pourquoi j'avais
choisi j'avais dû la voir dans un télé
poche mais mignonne et je trouvais que
c'était chic parce que c'était pas trop
connu non c'est normal
donc le fait de connaître son prénom ça
faisait un peu vrai si tu le sais tu es
et j'avais 45 ans ainsi que moi déjà
vainqueurs staline qui est sorti la
guajira caste indiqué sur tech des
moquettes jeu sorti quelques minutes
je crois que benjamin une relation avec
une spice girls
non c'est vrai j'ai une relation et que
spyker papa grand show dansant pas de
toi
un bisou bisou et a dit non mais alors
si c'est juste bisous on en a déjà fait
ensemble deux donjons nous deux on s'est
embrassés sur la bouche en déconnant pas
dur oui plus quand vous étiez tous les
deux ont su rallier mois part aux séries
tout cas c'est quelqu'un qui avait la
barbe le bateau non mais alors qu'elle
était à + bosch celle qu'elle est moins
jolie pardon saluer le sens du
d'encaisser pas non mais c'est
maintenant c'était très sympathique
après les gens n'arrêtaient de marmonner
noël je marmonne pas alors je dis que
les choses bougent taux n'atteint pas ce
qui s'est passé
donc voila c'était à l'époque où j'étais
travail chez michel drucker studio
gabriel
elle était invitée sur le sur les
bastions comme trop sympathique et très
très en forme non vous êtes sortira
après en boîte et c'est donc on
attendait a suivi ce qu'ils ont avec
michelle williams et riga le forestier
qui lui aussi en appel suffit alors
ouais mais quoi mais qui laquelle alors
elle c'était je crois que c'était la nbi
owens sallaberry xala c'est facile fille
assez facile du tout et c'était une
soirée très sympathique soirée et on
s'est dit c'est facile parce qu'ils
étaient des cars sont assez faciles
match a une relation avec une des filles
du groupe abba
dans ma catégorie d'âge laquelle la
moustache et les gipsy kings pendant des
années eva longoria eva longoria
oui mais c est quoi tu sais pas si c'est
pareil valloire savoie le cerveau l'a
jamais ça déjà sortir quelqu'un de connu
vers l'amont tiennent eux non c'est mon
ciel c'est pas vrai sinon les yeux bleus
qui disons que ça pêche veille de noël
allez c'est bon merci quoi maintenant
faille de marisa et maintenant ému bon
on s'en fout elle chante i alors oui je
te mentir alors pas et dont la fête de
noël a été choquée sur un bateau
d'ailleurs le bateau de jodie voilà
ouais merci et c'est une actrice qui
vont les jeunes connaissent pas mais l'a
fait savez vous aussi les jeunes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]